[Applaudissements]
[Musique] j'ai
regardé le film trois fois donc
j'ai dû venir dans ce coin
voir ces escaliers j'avais l'impression d'être dans
le film nous sommes venus ici dans les escaliers parce que
nous avons adoré le film du Joker
et d'un ami de  le mien est un ami insta, il
dit que nous devrions totalement venir ici
[Musique]
c'est irritant parce que les gens viennent ici
et ils veulent juste l'utiliser comme endroit
pour prendre des photos mais ils ne soutiennent pas les
communautés locales comme les laveries automatiques et les
dunnys et des trucs comme ça  ils
veulent juste venir ici et
l'utiliser comme une grosse blague comme si
les gens vivaient ici, que les
pauvres vivaient ici et ça
craint parce que vous savez qu'ils ne veulent pas
venir nous soutenir, ils veulent juste
venir  utilisez notre lieu de vie comme une
moquerie pour aimer qu'il y ait des moments amusants pour
leur page Instagram au motel et
ces marches ne sont pas les marches sur lesquelles vous voulez
être vous ne montez pas ces marches vous
savez descendez ces marches vous êtes  pas
d'ici, vous ne venez pas, vous avez
l'impression que c'est leur truc et maintenant
vous savez, avec l'ensemble de la ville de New York
dans son ensemble, où vous savez, les quartiers
sont en train de se gentrifier et des choses comme
ça, vous savez que vous avez ce genre de sentiment
de fierté où c'est comme si j'avais
été ici toute ma vie tout d'un coup
tu sais que cette chose arrive et maintenant nous
sommes importants tu sais et je comprends ce
point de vue mais en même temps comme
je l'ai dit, n'importe quelle publicité  Je pense que c'est comme
la publicité que je connais pour moi, le propriétaire,
qu'ils utilisent mon blog pour filmer et faire
un film comme je veux dire, je me sens heureux pour la
communauté, le souvenir des escaliers que j'ai,
c'est comme avoir peur de
monter le désordre  et le temps
et un chevalier et aussi, c'est comme savoir
qu'ils venaient de l'école et avoir
un cartable, c'était vraiment
un sentiment que j'ai maintenant, c'est un peu bizarre,
c'est comme un lieu de rencontre, tout le monde
téléphone, c'est intéressant, je sais qu'ils
sont vraiment en colère  là, ils crient
comme s'il n'y avait que des remous mais pour nous
peut-être pas parce que nous lisons pour vivre
ici si bien nous comprenons mais c'est
comme tout ce que vous savez comme vous vous
comprenez comme si c'était évidemment comme si
c'était si proche de votre cœur mais  alors tu
sais ça devient proche de tout le monde, c'est
cool en même temps maintenant les gens
ont une autre raison de venir au
Southern Yankee Stadium oh pourquoi pas
pourquoi ne pas venir dans le Bronx oh et je fais
voir aux gens qu'il y a d'autres parties de
la ville autres que  cette maison où si
tu veux entrer, dépense quelques dollars,
va à l'arrêt du pâté de maisons juste là,
dépense quelque chose 1 $ en aide sociale,
tu ne te vois pas